WE'RE GOING TO RECESS. ASSEMBLY
STILL IN SESSION.
SENATE COMMITTEE WILL AND
ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN
THE Þ STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 1200 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
EVERYONE TO THE SECOND BILL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY BILLS
FOR THE COMMITTEE IN 2024. WE
ARE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE HAVE SENATOR
BECKER IS GOING TO PRESENT IT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING'S AB 619.
YOU MAY. 69691. YOU MAY PROCEED.
SENATOR, I THANK YOU MEMBERS. I
AM PRESENTING 691 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION ON OR BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST, 2026, TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
REGARDING THE IMPACTS AND
EFFECTS OF INEFFICIENT HEATING,
VENTILATION AND AIR CONDITIONING
OR HVAC SYSTEMS AT SCHOOLS. IN
THE REPORT, THE CC WILL EVALUATE
FUTURE NEEDS AND POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS OF SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE
ENERGY EFFICIENT AND HAVE SAFE
VENTILATION IN SCHOOLS, OFTEN
HAVE HVAC SYSTEMS AND PLUMBING
FIXTURES THAT ARE UNHEALTHY FOR
STUDENTS AND USE EXCESSIVE
AMOUNTS OF WATER AND ENERGY. THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HEALTHY AIR,
PLUMBING AND EFFICIENCY, OR CAL
SHAPE PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
THROUGH ASSEMBLYMAN TING'S
PREVIOUS BILL, AB 841, IN 2020
THAT PROVIDES FUNDING TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SO THEY CAN UPGRADE HVAC
SYSTEMS AND REPLACE
NON-COMPLIANT OR WATER
INEFFICIENT PLUMBING FIXTURES AS
THIS PROGRAM IS TO SUNSET IN
2026, DECEMBER 1ST OF 2026, IT
IS CRITICAL THAT THE CC CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THE IMPACTS OF
INEFFICIENT HVAC SYSTEM AND
PROVIDE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HELP THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS HVAC AND
ENERGY SYSTEMS. IN TERMS OF
WITNESSES, I'M NOT I'M NOT DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE ANY. OKAY. DO WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES?
SEEING NONE WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 691.
SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
691? SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK FOR QUESTIONS. DO NOT MAKE
A MOTION UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM.
BUT I JUST COMMIT TO MAKING THE
MOTION WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. GOOD. BILL YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY
Kò ON BEHALF OF SIMILAR RATING
ASKED FOR. I VOTE ON THIS BILL
THAT WILL IMPROVE HEALTH AS WELL
AS ENERGY AND WATER USE IN OUR
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. WE WILL LEAVE THE WE'LL
TAKE THAT BILL UP WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM. ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT
WE HAVE 11 BILLS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY. TWO BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1176 ZUBIATE
GENERAL PLANS AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 1533 ENERGY AND
UTILITIES AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB 2239 BONTA DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION ACCESS
PROHIBITION.
SPECIAL.
WE WILL RECESS UNTIL WE GET
MEMBERS, AUTHORS, AND MEMBERS.
THEY HAVE ADJOURNED. ASSEMBLY IS
ADJOURNED.
STILL LACKING A QUORUM. BUT WE
DO HAVE AN AUTHOR. WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AND SHE HAS TWO MEASURES. AB
2292 AND 2815. YOU'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH 22, 92. YES, PLEASE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. WELL, GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATORS, AND THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2292.
THIS IS A SIMPLE MEASURE WHICH
WILL REPEAL THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES
TO PROSPECTIVE TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS BEFORE ISSUING A
PERMITTING APPROVAL. THE REASON
FOR THAT IS THAT THAT IS AN
ENTIRELY DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENT. SO TODAY,
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS ARE
REVIEWED TWICE TO DETERMINE IF
THEY ARE NEEDED ONCE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATORS TRANSMISSION PLANNING
PROCESS, AND THEN ONCE AGAIN
UNDER THE CPUC. THIS CERTIFICATE
OF PUBLIC CONVENIENCE AND
NECESSITY PERMIT. I KNOW THAT WE
ARE ALL WORKING TO FIND
RESPONSIBLE WAYS TO ACCELERATE
THE PACE OF CLEAN ENERGY
DEPLOYMENT. THIS IS A MODEST
CHANGE, BUT ONE WHICH WE HOPE
WILL LEAD TO THAT ACCELERATED
THÀNH. WITH THAT, I AM PLEASED
TO WELCOME JAN SMUTNY JONES WITH
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS AND
MICHAEL COLVIN, WHO REPRESENTS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
WE'LL LET YOU SIT DOWN. SMUTNY.
I KNOW YOU PROBABLY CAN'T STAND
UP LONG. I'M NOT THAT OLD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. JONES. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, I'M JAN SWEENEY JONES WITH
THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE ALL
NEED TO BE MOVING TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS ALONG A LITTLE FASTER
THAN WE HAVE BEEN, THIS BILL
DOES REMOVE AN ARCHAIC SOME
ARCHAIC LANGUAGE THAT'S NOT ONLY
DUPLICATIVE, IT IS. IT'S BEEN IN
THE CODE SECTION FOR A LONG
TIME, BEFORE WE'VE DEVELOPED OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. SO THE CURRENT
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IS DEVELOPED
OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLAN, THE IRP. THERE'S
ALL KINDS OF OTHER PROGRAMS THEY
LOOK AT AND PUTTING THE IRP
TOGETHER. AND THAT IS USED THEN
BY THE ISO TO COME UP WITH A
TRANSMISSION PLAN WHEN THE ISO
WAS PROPOSING BASICALLY A
TRANSMISSION PLAN, IT IS THE
PROCESS THEY USE IT, THEY DO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES TO
BUILDING THAT TRANSMISSION. SO
IN OTHER WORDS, IF SOMEONE CAN
COME FORWARD WITH WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD, YOU KNOW, SOME WE'RE
GOING TO PUT SOME, STORAGE
FACILITIES IN WHERE THE LINE IS
RATHER THAN THE LINE ITSELF. AND
THAT WILL SOLVE A PROBLEM THEN
THAT'S ALREADY CONSIDERED, SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL, IT'S, YOU KNOW, IT'S A
VERY SMALL THING, BUT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE WE'RE COMING UP ON
DEADLINES PRETTY QUICK. AND IF
WE DON'T START BUILDING THE
TRANSMISSION IN ORDER TO GET TO
THOSE DEADLINES, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MAKE IT. AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT ONE MORE THING. THIS
IS REMOVING A CODE SECTION THAT
ONLY APPLIES TO TRANSMISSION,
NOT DISTRIBUTION. SO I KNOW THAT
JUST TO NOT CONFUSE THINGS, IT'S
THE LARGER PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? GOOD AFTERNOON, MICHAEL
COLEMAN WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND, JUST TO KEEP
THINGS REALLY BRIEF, I THINK
THAT ONE, I REALLY APPRECIATE
HITTING THE DELETE KEY ON A
BILL. IT'S REALLY HELPFUL, TO
RATHER THAN ADDING A WHOLE LOT
OF NEW LANGUAGE, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BY REMOVING THIS
REDUNDANCY, WE'RE SAVING BOTH
TIME AND MONEY FOR CUSTOMERS.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE STILL
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE EVALUATION, TO
CONSIDER A NON WIRES
ALTERNATIVE. THIS JUST DOESN'T
NEED TO BE DONE MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND IT'S JUST, IT'S JUST
UNNECESSARY. AND IF THERE ARE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION OUT THERE
THAT SAYS OH WELL WE'RE CONFUSED
ABOUT THE PROCESS, THERE'S STILL
LOTS OF ON RAMPS TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS ANALYSIS. WE JUST DON'T
NEED TO DO IT THIS TIME IN THIS
PLACE. AND WITH THAT, EDF,
THANKS. YOU ARE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NOW FOR
ME TOS IN SUPPORT OF 2292 MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS, JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. ANDREW
CAUSSIDIERE WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
VALERIE CHIRLA ALEJO'S, PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY SUPPORT
. JOSE SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT. MELISSA
CORTEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NONE NOW.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. YOU ARE THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. YES. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. I BELIEVE
WE'RE THE ONLY OPPOSITION, MY
NAME IS KEVIN JOHNSTON. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION, OUR
OPPOSITION TO AB 2292 COMES AS
LANDOWNERS AND RATEPAYERS VERSUS
LANDOWNERS WHO ALREADY SUPPORT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE BELIEVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY SHOULD BE USED TO
EXPLORE A FULL RANGE OF
ALTERNATIVES AND DETERMINE
WHETHER A PROJECT IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY BEFORE TAKING PRIVATE
PROPERTY. ONCE UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PLACE, NOT
ONLY DOES THE LAND'S VALUE
DECREASE, BUT LIMITATIONS ON
USAGE AROUND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY ALTER OR
DIMINISH IN OPERATION. SECOND,
AS RATEPAYERS, I DON'T THINK I
NEED TO REMIND THIS COMMITTEE OF
THE NUMBER OF HEARINGS YOU'VE
HAD ABOUT AFFORDABILITY, AND AT
THE END OF ALL OF THOSE
HEARINGS, THE TREND LINE HAS
STILL BEEN GOING UPWARD.
TRANSMISSION COSTS MONEY. IT'S
GOING TO BE ABOUT 30 BILLION,
WHICH I THINK IS PROBABLY A LOW
ESTIMATE OVER THE NEXT 20 YEARS.
ANY ARGUMENT OF SPEED CREATING
SOME KIND OF COST SAVINGS
ASSUMES THAT A PROJECT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE NECESSARY. THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IS
TASKED WITH SETTING RATES AND
MANAGING AFFORDABILITY, BUT ALSO
DEMAND RESPONSE, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE PRIMARY ALTERNATIVES. AMONG
OTHER THINGS. THAT IS NOT
KAISER'S MISSION. THEY ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO 1002.3 IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS, THE ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT LAMENT THAT THE PUC
WOULD REACH A DIFFERENT
CONCLUSION TO CAISO. TO ME, THAT
SEEMS LIKE THE SYSTEM'S WORKING.
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY A DUPLICATIVE
REVIEW. THE PUC BRINGS A
DIFFERENT LENS, DIFFERENT
EXPERTISE, AND SHOULD DO ITS JOB
OF ENSURING THAT BEFORE WE DIG
DEEPER INTO RATEPAYERS POCKETS,
A PROJECT MUST ABSOLUTELY BE
NECESSARY AND HAVE NO VIABLE
ALTERNATIVES FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? YOU CAN COME FORWARD
NOW SEEING NONE, BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SEEING NONE
MOVE THE BILL? WELL, WE'RE SHORT
OF A QUORUM YET. I SAID YOU HAVE
A QUESTION. I'M SORRY. I HAD A
QUESTION, SENATOR EGGMAN, CAN
YOU CAN YOU RESPOND A LITTLE BIT
TO THE, THE FARM BUREAU'S
OPPOSITION? YES. AND THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR THAT. YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ROBUST PARTICIPATION AT EVERY
STAGE. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT BEING
DUPLICATIVE IN THE PLANNING
PROCESS. SO THE CAISO
TRANSMISSION PLANNING PROCESS
DOES CREATE LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES WITH WORKSHOPS AND
PUBLIC COMMENT FILINGS FOR
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING
NON-ENERGY INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS, TO ENGAGE AND
PROVIDE COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK.
SO, AB 2292 ONLY REPEALS THE
CPUC REVIEW FOR TRANSMISSION
PROJECT. IT DOES NOT ALTER THE
COMMISSION'S UNDERLYING
LICENSING AUTHORITY, NOR ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
RESPONSIBILITIES, AND THERE'S NO
EMINENT DOMAIN OR ANYTHING AS
ANY PART OF THIS. YEAH THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER, THANK YOU
FOR WORKING ON THIS. I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT, THE IDEA OF GETTING RID
OF DUPLICATIVE ANALYSIS. I JUST
HAD A QUESTION, SO YOU'VE
ALREADY LOOKED AT THIS THEN.
THEN IT WILL BE MOSTLY
DUPLICATIVE FOR THE PUC, WE DID
HAVE KIND OF A CONCERN ABOUT
DELETING THE SECTION REQUIRING
THE CONSIDERATION OF NON WIRE
ALTERNATIVES. AND I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS, IS IT ALWAYS THE
CASE. DOES THIS APPLY ONLY TO,
SITUATIONS WHERE FOR THE CAISO
HAS MADE THAT DETERMINATION? YES
OKAY. YES. EXACTLY. SO THE
REASON THAT YOU WOULD NOT NEED
THE PUC TO CONSIDER A NON WIRE
ALTERNATIVE IS THAT THE KAISER'S
PLANNING PROCESS HAS ALREADY
WEIGHED THAT ALTERNATIVE AND
DETERMINED THAT, IN FACT, WIRES
ARE NEEDED. GREAT. I JUST WANT
TO CONFIRM THAT THE INTENT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. YEAH. THANK
YOU, VICE CHAIR DARLING. SO I
JUST WANT TO ASK AGAIN. THE
SENATOR EGGMAN BROUGHT UP
EMINENT DOMAIN. THE UTILITIES
HAVE THE POWER TO DO EMINENT
DOMAIN. SO IF THEY'RE PUTTING IN
A NEW LINE, THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO USE EMINENT DOMAIN
AS A AS A VEHICLE TO PUT THAT
TRANSMISSION IN. AND THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING THAT. BUT SO BUT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE OR
ENHANCE OR EXPAND ANY OF THAT.
IT DOES NOT TOUCH ON THAT
QUESTION. RIGHT. SO I SO THE
REASON THE FARM BUREAU IS IN
OPPOSITION IS BECAUSE THEY CAN
JUST COME IN AND TAKE YOUR LAND
AND PUT POWER LINES ACROSS IT.
THIS BILL IS GIVING THE POWER TO
THE TO THE, CAL ISO. BUT IT'S
STILL A TRANSMISSION COMPANY HAS
THE POWER TO TAKE EMINENT
DOMAIN. SO I THINK THAT HAS TO
BE CLEAR. THAT'S THE REASON WHY
THE FARM BUREAU IS OPPOSING. OR
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, BUT I
BELIEVE THEY DO HAVE THE POWER.
SO IT'S NOT THAT THE UTILITIES
CAN JUST, YOU KNOW, COME IN AND
TAKE EMINENT DOMAIN. IT IS AFTER
A ROBUST REGULATORY AND REVIEW
PROCESS THAT WOULD THEN THAT
WOULD CONTINUE TO BE CONDUCTED
BY CAISO THAT DETERMINES THAT
THIS IS NECESSARY, NEEDED AND
REQUIRED. SO IT WOULD NOT CHANGE
OR EXPAND ANY OF THAT AUTHORITY.
RIGHT. BUT YOU SAID IT DIDN'T
HAVE THE POWER. IT DOES HAVE.
THE UTILITIES HAVE THE POWER FOR
EMINENT DOMAIN, WHICH MEANS IF
THAT RIGHT OF WAY WAS DEEMED
NECESSARY AND CORRECT, IT MET
ALL THE PUBLIC PROCESSES THEY
CAN TAKE YOUR LAND, WHICH SO AS
IS AS IS THE CASE TODAY. SO THIS
BILL, YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S THAT
IS CURRENT LAW. YES. AND IT
TAKES AWAY ONE OF THE LEVELS OF
REVIEW, WHICH IS WHY THE FARM
BUREAU IS OPPOSED, BECAUSE
THEY'D LIKE ALL THE LEVEL LEVELS
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK. RIGHT? YES.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? AGAIN, WE'RE
STILL LACKING A QUORUM,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
YOU NEXT ITEM IS 2815, SO THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AB 2815 WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA TO MODERNIZE EXISTING
EV CHARGING STATIONS AND IMPROVE
THE EV CONSUMER EXPERIENCE BY
EXPANDING ELIGIBLE FUNDING TO
REPAIR OR REPLACE OLDER AND
INOPERABLE EV CHARGING STATIONS
SUCH THAT THEY MEET TODAY'S
STANDARDS. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY TEAM ON THIS
BILL, AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. CALIFORNIA
HAS LED THE NATION WHEN IT COMES
TO THE TRANSITION FROM INTERNAL
COMBUSTION VEHICLES TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. TODAY,
CALIFORNIA HAS APPROXIMATELY
94,000 PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS.
WE NEED TO BUILD 2.1 MILLION
PUBLIC AND SHARED LIGHT DUTY
CHARGERS BY 2035 TO MEET THE
INCREASING DEMAND FOR CHARGING
SERVICES, AB 2015 WILL ENABLE
THE CEC TO ALLOCATE A PORTION OF
EXISTING FUNDS TO MODERNIZE
LEGACY CHARGING STATIONS THAT
ARE MORE THAN FIVE YEARS OLD.
WITH ME TODAY IS MEGAN
MICKELBERG WITH THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MEGAN MICKELBERG AND I REPRESENT
THE EV CHARGING ASSOCIATION
KNOWN AS AVCA, THE ASSOCIATION
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 2815,
WHICH WILL SUPPORT THE
MODERNIZATION OF INOPERABLE EV
CHARGERS THAT ARE IN NEED OF
REPAIRS OR REPLACEMENT. THE
ASSOCIATION OR THE INTRODUCTION
OF THE MASS MARKET OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IN 2010. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN AN UNEQUIVOCAL LEADER IN
SUPPORTING THE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIDESPREAD CHARGING NETWORK OVER
A DECADE INTO THE VEHICLE
TRANSITION, MANY PUBLIC EV
CHARGERS ARE NEARING THE END OF
THEIR USEFUL LIFE. AT THE SAME
TIME, EV CHARGING TECHNOLOGY HAS
ADVANCED RAPIDLY IN RECENT
YEARS, AND MANY LEGACY CHARGERS
DO NOT HAVE THE SAME PERFORMANCE
THAT EV CHARGERS EV DRIVERS HAVE
COME TO EXPECT WITH TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGY. ADDITIONALLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
HAVE INSTITUTED A NUMBER OF NEW
REGULATIONS IN RECENT YEARS,
INCLUDING STANDARDS FOR PAYMENT,
ELECTRICITY DELIVERY,
RELIABILITY, CONNECTORS, AND
MORE. AB 2815 REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INCENTIVIZE THE
REPAIR AND REPLACEMENT OF
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET
TODAY'S STANDARDS, WHICH WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
OPERATIONAL CHARGERS AND ENHANCE
THE RELIABILITY OF THE EXISTING
FLEET OF INFRASTRUCTURE. BY
INCENTIVIZING THIS, IT WILL MAKE
MORE, YOU KNOW, MORE CHARGERS
AVAILABLE. AND IMPORTANTLY, THE
FUNDS DO HAVE TO BE MATCHED BY
ANY, YOU KNOW, OWNER AND
OPERATOR. AND 50% OF THE FUNDS
DO NEED TO GO TO DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE ARE HAPPY TO
SPONSOR AB 2815. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF 2815?
YES. STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. JULIE
MALINOWSKI BALL, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT, WE NEED TO MAINTAIN
WHAT WE'VE GOT TODAY AS
INCLUDING BUILDING NEW, WHICH IS
WHY WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. HELLO,
MICHELLE CARNALIS, UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT. THAT'S IMPRESSED WITH
ADVANCED ENERGY, UNITED AND
STRONG SUPPORT. MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK FENSTERMAKER FOR
PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS GROGAN ON BEHALF
OF CHARGEPOINT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO, CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
DEREK DOLPHIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OKAY. LOOKS LIKE ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NOW LET'S
GO TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE WITNESSES HERE AND THE
ROOM OPPOSED TO 2815 SEEING
NONE. I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
SENATOR DURAZZO? YEAH. COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHO'S GOING TO GET THE
FUNDING THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING? I
MEAN, WHO YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
WHOLE WEB HERE OF WHO MAKES THE
CHARGING, WHO MAKES THE CHARGES,
WHO BUILDS THE CHARGES, AND THEN
THEY GET, YOU KNOW, PUT
SOMEWHERE AND THEN THERE'S
MAINTENANCE AND, SO WHERE DOES
THIS FUNDING COME IN AND WHO IS
IT GOING TO HELP? SO THE CEC HAS
FUNDING ALLOCATED. YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE ALLOCATED FUNDING TO THE
CEC FOR A NUMBER OF GRANT
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO ACCELERATE,
THE, THE BUILD OUT OF THE EV
CHARGING NETWORK, THAT IS OR,
YOU KNOW, THE, THE ZEV CHARGING
NETWORK THAT IS SO, SO CRITICAL
FOR US TO ACTUALLY ENABLE
CALIFORNIANS TO CHARGE VEHICLES,
FEEL CONFIDENT BUYING THESE
VEHICLES AND SO THE IT WOULD NOT
CHANGE WHO'S ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
GRANTS UNDER THE CEC. IT WOULD
SIMPLY SAY THAT A PORTION OF THE
FUNDING CAN BE USED IN ADDITION
TO BUILDING OUT NEW CHARGING
STATIONS TO UPGRADE CHARGING
STATIONS THAT ARE MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS OLD THAT ARE OPERATING
UNDER OBSOLETE TECHNOLOGY AND
ARE OFTEN BROKEN AND IN
DISREPAIR, THE LOGIC BEING THAT
IT'S CHEAPER TO, UPGRADE THOSE
EXISTING SITES, RATHER THAN END
UP WITH A STRANDED ASSET SO IT
DOESN'T CHANGE WHO'S ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT APPLICATION. IT SIMPLY
SAYS THAT A PORTION OF THE FUNDS
CAN BE USED TO UPGRADE AND
UPDATE LEGACY INFRASTRUCTURE.
YEAH. I'M JUST I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HERE WHO'S WHO'S
GOING TO APPLY, WHO'S APPLYING
FOR THIS FUNDING AND WHO'S
GETTING THE FUNDING. I THOUGHT
THERE WAS SOME MEASURE OF
RESPONSIBILITY BY THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THE OF THE
CHARGERS OR BY WHOEVER OWNS THE
LAND WHERE THE CHARGERS ARE
ACTUALLY PUT ON. YES. IS WHO IS
THE APPLICANT WHO ASKED FOR THE
MONEY AND IN SOME CASES THAT IS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO WHO ARE
INSTALLING THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS PART OF
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND IN SOME
CASES, IT IS IN LINE WITH THE
OTHER EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS.
IT IS PRIVATE ENTITIES WHO ARE
LEVERAGING THESE FUNDS TO MORE
QUICKLY ACCELERATE THEIR BUILD
OUT OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
THERE'S NO, THERE'S NO
COMMITMENT OR RESPONSIBILITY TO
UPGRADE AND UP, MAINTAIN AND
SERVICE THESE CHARGERS BY ANYONE
WHEN THEY'RE PUT IN. IS THAT
LIKE AND THAT'S AND I APPRECIATE
YOU YOU MAKING THAT POINT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
KNOW IN THE SENATE AS WELL I'M
SURE YOU'VE HAD HEARINGS ABOUT
JUST THE FRUSTRATIONS PEOPLE
FEEL WHEN THEY GO TO, YOU KNOW,
THESE CHARGING STATIONS AND FIND
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT
WORKING. AND WE HAVE AS A
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS, I THINK, TAKEN A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S REALLY ROBUST
ACCOUNTABILITY. AN ATTACHED TO
THE EXPENDITURE OF THESE DOLLARS
. I THINK THAT THE REALITY IS
WHEN SOME OF THIS MONEY WAS
FIRST GOING OUT THE DOOR, YOU
KNOW, FIVE YEARS AGO, TEN YEARS
AGO, THERE WASN'T SUFFICIENT
ACCOUNTABILITY ATTACHED WITH
THAT, THE REASON THAT WE ARE
RESTRICTING THESE UPGRADE FUNDS
TO THE PROJECTS THAT WERE BUILT
MORE THAN FIVE YEARS AGO IS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S IN LEGITIMATE NEED OF
AN UPGRADE, IF THAT, IF THAT
MAKES SENSE. SO IT'S NOT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS
INSTALLED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
AND HAS JUST BEEN ALLOWED TO
DETERIORATE AND HASN'T BEEN
MAINTAINED, AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE THEM MORE MONEY. IT IS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS
INSTALLED FIVE YEARS AGO WHERE
WE REALLY DO NEED TO UPGRADE THE
TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER FOR THOSE
STATIONS TO BE VIABLE ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS, AND IT WILL
CONTINUE. IT WILL HAVE THE SAME
ROBUST ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
THAT WE'RE NOW BUILDING IN TO
ANY DOLLAR THAT'S ATTACHED TO
THOSE FUNDING. YEAH YEAH. AND
THANK YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING THAT.
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE GO TO ANY
MORE QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS
SECRETARY, LET'S CALL THE ROLL
AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM OKAY
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. HERE. DELI.
DELI HERE. ASHBY HERE. ASHBY.
HERE. BECKER. BECKER. HERE.
CABALLERO DODD. DODD. HERE.
DURAZZO HERE. DURAZZO. HERE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. HERE. GONZALEZ
GROVE. GROVE. HERE. LEMON MIN.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. HERE. RUBIO
CIERTO. SKINNER. STERN. STERN
HERE. WILK. A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED, ARE THERE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE? RIGHT HERE. SENATOR
DALLI. I LIKE YOUR BILL. WELL,
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT. WE ENTERTAIN
A MOTION. SO MOVED. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, I
WOULD. WELL, THANK YOU, SENATORS
, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE CLERK. CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. AS AMENDED TO SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
OKAY. YES, DO PASS, AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATION. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. I DALI I DALI I ASHBY
I ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
CABALLERO. DODD. DODD I DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I EGGMAN GONZALEZ.
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. GROVE GROVE I
LEMON. MIN. NEWMAN NEWMAN I
RUBIO. CIERTO. SKINNER STERN A
STERN I WILK. TEN. ALL RIGHT, 10
TO 0. THANK YOU, SENATOR. TEN
ZERO WILL, LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
ADD ONS. THANK YOU. DO YOU WANT
TO OPEN THE ROLL ON THE OTHER
BILLS? YES. REAL QUICK. LET'S
OPEN THE ROLL ON THE OTHER BILLS
WE HAD. SO WE'LL START OUT WITH
NUMBER ONE AB 691 TÍNH. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION MR. YEAH OKAY. LET'S SEE.
DO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AB 691 TÍNH
BRADFORD. DALLI. DALLI NØ ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER I.
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO. DODD
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE NO.
LEMON. MIN. NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE.
RUBIO. CIERTO SKINNER. STERN.
STERN AYE. WILK 7 TO 2. SEVEN
TWO. WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL FOR ADD ONS, WE HAVE NOW
ITEM FOR AB 2292, WHICH IS? WE
NEED A MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY EGGMAN, AND IT IS DUE PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE. BRADFORD
DALLI. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
BECKER I BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
DODD DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE LIMON. MINH
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO SATO.
SKINNER. STERN A STERN. AYE.
WILK 7070. WILL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL. MEMBERS. WE HAD TWO
THREE ITEMS THAT WERE PULLED.
ITEM NUMBER TWO, ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AND ITEM NUMBER TEN. JUST
TO LET YOU KNOW, WE'LL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER SIX, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AB 1826. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT, THE AB 1826, A DIGITAL
EQUITY AND VIDEO FRANCHISING ACT
OF 2024. I WANT TO FIRST BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF, AND I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE GOING FORWARD WITH THIS
BILL. DOES IS THAT AB 1826 WILL
UPDATE THE DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT OF 2006 TO
CREATE A ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS
MÁS TO ALLOW FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN ONCE
STREAMLINED PROCESS. AS YOU MAY
AS YOU MAY KNOW, I'VE WORKED ON
REVISING DIVKA FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IT'S ONE OF THE TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO TACKLE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
COMPARED TO AB 41, THIS BILL
DOES NOT CONTAIN THE EQUAL
ACCESS PROVISIONS OF SAFE HARBOR
DELETIONS, BUT WOULD INCREASE
FINES FOR VIOLATIONS OF CERTAIN
CUSTOMER SERVICE RULES AND GIVES
GREATER OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROUPS
AND INDIVIDUALS TO ENGAGE IN
CABLE FRANCHISE APPLICATIONS AND
RENEWALS. AS STATED ON PAGE SIX
OF THE COMMITTEE, ANALYSIS AB
1826 WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE CPUC
TO INCLUDE IN ITS ANNUAL REPORT
A PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT FOR
EACH FRANCHISE. THE VETO MESSAGE
BY THE GOVERNOR ON AB 41
HIGHLIGHTS THE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS, THE STATE HAS MADE
TO INCREASE DIGITAL EQUITY, AND
EMPHASIZES THAT WE MUST BUILD ON
THESE EFFORTS AND CONSIDER
STRATEGIC REFORMS TO THE POLICY
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL. AB 1826
FOCUSES ON UTILIZING TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE THROUGH
THE DIFFICULT STATUTE. BEFORE
DIFFICU CABLE FRANCHISING WAS
DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
ENSURE THE COMMUNITY'S NEEDS ARE
MET AS A CONDITION OF HOLDING A
FRANCHISE. AB 1826 WOULD ALIGN
DEVCO WITH FEDERAL LAW BY
ESTABLISHING A RENEWAL PROCESS
THAT AUTHORIZES THE CPC TO
INITIATE A PROCEEDING TO RECEIVE
PUBLIC INPUT, AND COMPLETE A
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION FOR EACH
FRANCHISE HOLDER. LASTLY, AB
1826 WILL INCREASE THE FINES FOR
ANY CUSTOMER SERVICE COMPLAINTS
IN FORCE BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
LETICIA ALVAREZ, DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND COMMUNICATIONS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY FUND. WELCOME. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. LETICIA ALEJANDRO
IS DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
FUND, FIRST, WE'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY EXPRESSING OUR APPRECIATION
THÀNH TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN REVISITING
VIDEO FRANCHISING. IN THIS BILL,
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES FUND TECHNOLOGY
FUNDS MISSION IS TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE, PROMOTE DIGITAL
INCLUSION, AND ACHIEVE DIGITAL
EQUITY IN CALIFORNIA. CITF
SUPPORTED THIS, THE PRECURSOR TO
THIS BILL, AB 41, BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN, AND AGAIN, THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE WAS VERY
INSTRUCTIVE WITH REFERENCE TO
THE NEED FOR A STRONGER BILL FOR
DEPLOYMENT AS WELL AS THE
REFERENCE TO AFFORDABILITY. CTF
IS TAKING THE VETO MESSAGE AS
INSTRUCTIONS FOR AB 1826 AND THE
OTHER DIGITAL EQUITY BILLS THAT
WILL BE COMING BEFORE YOU. CETF.
CETF APPRECIATES THE WISDOM OF
REVISITING VIDEO FRANCHISING AS
A POWERFUL VEHICLE FOR CLOSING
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE, PROMOTING
DIGITAL INCLUSION AND ACHIEVING
DIGITAL EQUITY. WE WANT TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND STAKEHOLDERS IN GETTING THIS
BILL RIGHT TO SECURE THE
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE. THE BILL
WOULD REVISE EXISTING LAW
PERTAINING TO STATEWIDE VIDEO
FRANCHISES TO ADVANCE A FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT RENEWAL PROCESS AT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THIS BILL IS
IMPERATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
VIDEO FRANCHISING PROCESS, AND
THERE ARE KEY PROVISIONS THAT WE
SO APPRECIATE WITH REGARD TO
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN HEARINGS
, GUARANTEES OF FRANCHISORS,
UPHOLDING THEIR COMMITMENTS AND
DELIVERING ON THEIR PROMISE. AND
IT EMPOWERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ENFORCE CUSTOMER SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS EFFECTIVELY. AB
1826 IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STRENGTHEN DIVKA TO ACCELERATE
PROGRESS ON UBIQUITOUS
DEPLOYMENT AND UNIVERSAL
ADOPTION, TO ACHIEVE DIGITAL
EQUITY. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AB 1826. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
IN ROOM 1200, SEEING NONE,
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
AMANDA GUADERRAMA WITH CAL
BROADBAND. I'D FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON AB 1826. WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
TO BE CLEAR, DVCA DOES NOT
REGULATE BROADBAND AND ONLY
TRADITIONAL CABLE ENTERTAINMENT
VIDEO SERVICE. AS THE ANALYSIS
NOTES, WE HAVE SEEN THIS BILL IN
DIFFERENT FORMS FOR A FEW YEARS
NOW. LAST YEAR, CAL BROADBAND
WAS ABLE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
AUTHOR AND GO NEUTRAL ON AB 41
BEFORE THE SENATE FLOOR, AB 41
WAS A COMPROMISE. NO PARTY
RECEIVED EVERYTHING THEY WANTED,
BUT THAT IS USUALLY THE SIGN OF
A WELL NEGOTIATED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. UNFORTUNATELY THE
GOVERNOR DISAGREED AND VETOED
THE BILL. CAL BROADBAND HAS HAS
NOT BEEN TOLD BY THE
ADMINISTRATION EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE OUT OF A BILL
AMENDING THE STATUTE AB 1826, AS
INTRODUCED, DID NOT START FROM
OUR NEGOTIATED LANGUAGE IN AB
41, INSTEAD STARTED FROM A
POSITION WHERE CAL BROADBAND WAS
OPPOSED. THUS, THE ASSOCIATION
IS COMPELLED TO OPPOSE 1820. AB
1826. WE ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, BUT
BELIEVE THEY TAKE THE BILL IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION, SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE THIS COMMITTEE DID LAST
YEAR WITH AB 41. AND WE AGAIN
APPLAUD THAT MOVEMENT. WHAT IS
DIFFERENT THIS YEAR IS THAT THE
CPUC IS CURRENTLY UNDERGOING A
PROCEEDING TO CONSIDER CHANGES
TO ITS LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT
OF VIDEO FRANCHISES UNDER THE
DFCA STATUTE. THE PROCEEDING
CONTEMPLATES MODERNIZING DIVKA
THE COLLECTION OF GRANULAR DATA
ON LOCATIONS SERVED BY FRANCHISE
HOLDERS, AND ADDRESSING CUSTOMER
SERVICE REQUIREMENTS AND
COMPLAINTS. CAL BROADBAND, OUR
MEMBERS, COMMUNITY ADVOCATES,
COUNTIES AND CITIES ARE ALL
PARTIES TO THIS PROCEEDING AT
THIS POINT, IT WOULD SEEM THAT
THE CPUC BELIEVES IT ALREADY HAS
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
MODERNIZE DIVKA, AND THAT
CHANGES TO THE STATUTE ARE
UNNECESSARY FOR ALL THE REASONS
STATED, CAL BROADBAND REMAINS
OPPOSED TO 1826. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS WISHING TO
ADD ON IS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS.
YOLANDA BENSON, ON BEHALF OF US
TELECOM, THE BROADBAND
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1826. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES,
WE'LL BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION. ANY QUESTIONS?
CONCERNS SEEING NONE, WOULD YOU?
I'D ENTERTAIN A MOTION. LIMON.
OH, YOU HAVE A QUESTION? YEAH.
DO YOU APOLOGIZE, THE NOTES THAT
I HAVE INDICATE THAT THAT THERE
WERE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED WHERE
WERE THEY ACCEPTED? YES, YES,
AND I HAVE THEM HERE. I'LL JUST
READ THEM OUT FOR, MEMBERS TO
KNOW, REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
PUBLIC HEARINGS REQUIRED FOR A
FRANCHISE RENEWAL TO TWO
HEARINGS, ONE OF WHICH MAY BE
CONDUCTED VIRTUALLY. OR TELL
TELEPHONICALLY, MOVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CPUC
EVALUATION OF EACH CABLE
FRANCHISE FROM THE APPLICATION
PROCESS TO THE CPUC. EXISTING
ANNUAL REPORT ON DIFFICU.
RESTORE EXISTING LAW FOR
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL REGARDING
FRANCHISE FEES. THE CPUC S
ABILITY TO TARIFF CABLE
FRANCHISES AND INFORMATION. THE
CPUC CAN REQUIRE AS PART OF AN
APPROVAL FRANCHISE APPLICATION,
AND IT MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL
CONFORMING CHANGES. THAT'S WHAT
I HAVE ON SENATOR BRADFORD'S
NOTES HERE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
YES YEAH. JUST APPRECIATE YOU
READING THAT OUT. I UNDERSTOOD
THERE WERE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS,
AND THEY WERE TAKING THEM. I HAD
HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW THEM, I
THOUGHT MAYBE THAT WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION. OBVIOUSLY IT HASN'T.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY, BUT DO YOU WANT TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY, AT THE, YOU
KNOW, AFTERWARDS TO READ THE
AMENDMENTS AND KIND OF RESERVE
THE RIGHT ON THE SENATE FLOOR,
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. AND I APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS FOR MANY YEARS. OKAY. NO
FURTHER COMMENTS. THEN WE WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SENATOR DO
YOU HAVE A QUESTION? YEAH, I
JUST ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
SENATOR BECKER THERE, AND I HOPE
WE YOU CAN WORK SOME OF THOSE
THINGS OUT. YEAH. APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY NOW WE WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR BILL MOVED BY. YES.
YOU MAY CLOSE, FIRST OF ALL, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE. NOT
ONLY THIS YEAR, BUT LAST YEAR. I
THINK IT WAS ALWAYS OUR
INTENTION TO TRY TO FIND A WAY,
A PATHWAY TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. AND I THINK
WE DID, AS YOU WILL RECALL LAST
YEAR, BY ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS, WE LOST OUR OUR
SUPPORTERS TO THE BILL. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IMPACT THAT HAD
ULTIMATELY ON THE VETO. BUT
CLEARLY WE WANTED TO START THIS
YEAR WITH AN UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW WE COULD STRENGTHEN THE
TRANSPARENCY COMPONENTS OF AND
MAKE IT BETTER, WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE FRESH FOR ALL OF
US AT THIS MOMENT, BUT WE HAD A
CHANCE TO READ THROUGH THEM AND
WE DO SUPPORT THEM AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO ARCHITECT. DIFFERENT
APPROACHES ALONG THE WAY TO SEE
IF WE CAN GET IT TO WHERE IT WAS
LAST YEAR, WHERE THERE'S THE
OPPOSITION IS PULLED BACK. SO
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE THANK YOU. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR STERN.
IT'S A DUE PASS TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BRADFORD. DALLY NØ DALLY NÓ
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ
GROVE. NO. GROVE. NO. LEMON.
MINH NEWMAN. RUBIO. SIERRA C .
SKINNER. STERN A STERN. AYE.
WILK 7 TO 2. 7 TO 2. WE'LL KEEP
THAT BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
DO NOT SEE. DO WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR? OH, THERE HE IS, HIDING
BEHIND THE PILLAR. THERE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. HE HAS
THREE BILLS. WHICH ONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO START WITH, SIR? WELL.
FILE ORDER. OKAY. AB 1834 1834.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL IS, AN
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION. THÀNH
TO AB 1373. IT'S THE CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT BILL THAT DID COME
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE. THE
CLARIFICATION ENSURE THAT
REVISED RELIABILITY PROVISIONS
OF THAT BILL CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
FAIRLY WITHOUT INCREASING
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS FOR
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES. WE
HAVE TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
SPEAK TO THE BILL. GREG COOK, ON
BEHALF OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY, AND
NATALIE SEITZMAN, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREG COOK, REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY. THE
ASSEMBLYMAN HAS EXPLAINED THE
BILL. HE PROVIDED GREAT
LEADERSHIP LAST YEAR IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AB 1373. THIS IS
A GOOD BILL FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU,
NATALIE SEITZMAN FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. LIKE THE ASSEMBLYMAN
SAID, THIS BILL MAKES
CLARIFICATIONS, TO AB 1373 TO
IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION, TO MAKE
THAT GO SMOOTHER, I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE ON THOSE ON
THOSE CLARIFICATIONS, THANK YOU.
AND I VOTE THANK YOU. OTHERS
HERE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. DEREK DOLPHY,
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI. MY NAME IS ELLEN
BRITTINGHAM. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SAN HERE IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY POWER.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
MANDY ISAACS LEE HERE ON BEHALF
OF AVA COMMUNITY ENERGY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
MORE SUPPORT, HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION TO AB 1834? SEEING
NONE. WE WILL BRING IT BACK.
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS. NO
QUESTIONS. SENATOR STERN. YEAH
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS. I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S AT
THE HEART OF YOUR BILL, WHICH I
KNOW IS REALLY SORT OF A,
ADJUSTMENT AROUND PU
PARTICIPATION. BUT IN TERMS OF
THE STRATEGIC RELIABILITY
RESERVE, ITS OPERATION IN
GENERAL, I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
YOU OR YOUR BILL SPONSORS OR
LEAD SUPPORTERS, BUT I DO HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THE CURRENT
OPERATION. THERE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE, THE
CONTRACT THAT ALL THIS, ALL
THESE FEES WOULD FUND, IT'S LIKE
A $2.2 BILLION GAS CONTRACT. AND
I WAS WONDERING BEFORE WE SORT
OF SIGN OFF ON, THE FUNDING
MECHANISM HERE, IF WE CAN GET AN
UPDATE ON, THE STATUS OF THAT
CONTRACT, I KNOW IT'S A TIGHT
BUDGET YEAR, AND I THINK WE PUT
$400 MILLION MORE TOWARDS THE
DIABLO PIECE, BUT I JUST WAS
WONDERING ABOUT THE GAS PIECE OF
THE CONTRACT. I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION, SENATOR, OKAY. WITH
ME. WE'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT. IS THAT SOMETHING
THE THAT THE SUPPORTERS MIGHT
HAVE? I'M LOOKING IN THAT
DIRECTION. HAS THAT MONEY BEEN
SPENT OR IS THAT. I DON'T HAVE
AN UPDATE ON THAT. SENATOR THIS
BILL DOESN'T MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
HOW THAT MONEY WILL BE SPENT. IT
DOESN'T. IT MAKES CHANGES FOR
HOW THE MONEY WOULD GO INTO FUND
THAT CONTRACT. RIGHT. SO IN THE
CASE THAT A CAPACITY PAYMENT
WOULD BE OWED, WHICH IS NOT THE
NORMAL FUNDING MECHANISM FOR THE
STRATEGIC LIABILITY RESERVE,
IT'S A, FUNDING MECHANISM IN THE
CASE THAT A LOAD SERVING ENTITY
OR PU, IS SHORT ON THEIR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY CAPACITY. SO
IT'S LIKE A KIND OF SECONDARY
FUNDING SOURCE. SO IT WOULD IT
WOULD MAKE CLARIFICATIONS INTO
HOW THAT WOULD WORK. BUT IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDING OF THE STRATEGIC
LIABILITY RESERVE. SO THIS IS
BUT BUT IT'S STILL THE FUNDS
FROM THE PAYMENTS AUTHORIZED IN
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD IN THEORY
OFFSET THE COST OF THAT, THAT
CONTRACT. THE THEORY WOULD BE IF
THE UTILITY IS SURE AND USES
CAPACITY FROM THE STRATEGIC
LIABILITY RESERVE AS LIKE WHAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THEIR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY CAPACITY THAT THIS IS
THEM REIMBURSED THAT FUND.
RIGHT. I GUESS I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET A SENSE BECAUSE WE JUST
CUT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OUT OF THE CLEAN ENERGY
RELIABILITY INVESTMENT PLAN IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET CUT DSG'S CUT
DIBA. HOW MUCH OF THE LIKE ARE
WE GOING TO KEEP RELYING ON THE
GENERAL FUND, I GUESS, TO FUND
THAT LARGE GAS CONTRACT VERSUS,
SAY, THE PAYMENTS AUTHORIZED IN
THIS LEGISLATION? MAYBE WE COULD
FOLLOW UP ON THAT ITEM. WE'D
LIKE TO. OKAY ANY. DO YOU HAVE
FURTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR? 15
MILLION SINCE FEBRUARY. GOT IT,
GOT IT. SO THEY SPENT DOWN SIX.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS, WE WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. OKAY. I'M OVER THIS.
SENATOR CABALLERO, I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED, BECAUSE IT'S, IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OPAQUE IN TERMS OF
EXACTLY HOW THE FUND, AT LEAST
TO ME, HOW THE FUND IS, IS,
REIMBURSED, IF YOU WILL. AND
WHO'S THE PRIMARY AND THE
SECONDARY? THE PRIMARY AND THE
SECONDARY, PAYMENTS THAT ARE
MADE. AND SO, THE SUFFICE IT TO
SAY THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY, BUT LOOKING VERY
CAREFULLY AT IT AS WE LOOK AT
APPROPRIATIONS, BECAUSE GIVEN
THE STATE OF OUR BUDGET, DOESN'T
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE TO ME FOR
OUR GENERAL FUND TO BE FUNDING
SOMETHING THAT WE JUST CAN'T
AFFORD RIGHT NOW. AND WE DID
MAKE SOME CHANGES. SO I'LL
SUPPORT IT. BUT, I WANT TO LOOK
AT IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
CRITICALLY. SO IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE, WE COULD GET THE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE MUCH
APPRECIATED. OKAY, SO I WILL
MOVE THE BILL. OKAY. AND I HAVE
A I HAVE A FOLLOW UP COMMENT OR
QUESTION. SO THIS THIS FUND IS
BASICALLY AVAILABLE FOR MAKE
SURE WE HAVE POWER WHEN WE HAVE
BIG SWINGS IN THE EVENTS. AND IF
WE DON'T HAVE THAT BACKUP WE
HAVE OUTAGES. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED ON
HERE. I KNOW THAT THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY SOME THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
POWER WE'RE GETTING AT THOSE
TIMES, BUT WE NEED THAT POWER.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY. I KNOW IT MAY NOT BE
PERFECT, BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IF WE HAVE BIG HEAT EVENTS
AND WE NEED THAT POWER, WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON. WHO SAID IT'S NOT PERFECT,
WE JUST GOT CLARIFICATION ON
YOUR ANALYSIS. IT POINTS OUT TO
THE ACTUAL COST THAT WAS
ALLOCATED, HOW MUCH HAS BEEN
DRAWN DOWN. AND IT'S BEEN
CONFIRMED THAT THE BILL DOESN'T
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THAT OVERALL,
BUDGET. SO I THINK WE ANSWERED
THE OR SHE ANSWERED, THE
SENATOR'S QUESTION AND WE WON'T
HAVE A NEED TO MEET WITH HIM ON
THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE, BUT I'M
HAPPY TO HANG OUT WITH HIM
ANYTIME. IF HE WANTS TO GET
TOGETHER. SO I THINK THE POINT I
WAS TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT WE
NEED THIS YES PROCESS SO THAT WE
HAVE POWER WHEN THERE'S SWINGS
IN OUR POWER. YEP. SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT, SO WOULD WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR CABALLERO?
AND IT IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? JUST THANK YOU FOR
ENTERTAINING THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. DALY.
DALY. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE
AYE. GROVE. AYE. LIMÓN. MINH
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO.
CIERTO SKINNER. STERN. STERN.
AYE WILK. 11 TO 0. THAT MEASURE
HAS 11 VOTES. IT'S OUT. WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO AB 3280. 38. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND YOU KNOW,
SPEAKING ALONG THE LINES OF
NEEDING POWER AND THE ISSUE OF
RELIABILITY, I BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD, WHICH ACCELERATES THE
BUILDOUT OF OUR ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION TO MEET OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS.
ACHIEVING THESE GOALS WILL
REQUIRE UNPRECEDENTED
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROVIDE
RELIABLE RENEWABLE ENERGY TO
ELECTRIFY OUR HOMES, COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS, TRANSPORTATION. AND
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE SOME
BOLD MOVES IN THE POLICY SPACE.
THIS BILL CONTAINS PROVISIONS
CONSISTENT WITH THE 18 PARTY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT BEFORE THE
CPUC THAT WOULD MODIFY THE
EXISTING PERMITTING PROCESSES AT
THE CPUC TO STREAMLINE AND
ACCELERATE ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT. THIS
BILL WILL REMOVE DUPLICATION AND
ENSURE THE CPUC TIMELINE TO
PERMIT TRANSMISSION PROJECTS IS
EXPEDITED, WHILE STILL ENSURING
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. THIS BILL
ALSO CONTAINS A NARROWLY
TAILORED CEQA EXEMPTION THAT
WOULD EXEMPT THE ACQUISITION OF
AN EXPANSION OF RIGHT OF WAY FOR
ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE ON STATE OWNED
LAND, WHILE STILL REQUIRING
FINAL SIGN OFF FROM THE
LANDOWNER, AND FULL SCALE REVIEW
OF CONSTRUCTION OF PROPERTY OF
PROJECTS BY THE CPUC. SENATORS
THIS BILL HAS GONE THROUGH THREE
POLICY COMMITTEES AND I WOULD
COUNT FOUR BECAUSE THE
APPROPRIATIONS TOOK A POLICY
STAB AT IT AS WELL. SO FOR
REVIEWS IN THE ASSEMBLY AS WELL
AS FOR ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WHERE WE ATTEMPTED TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS FROM, A
LARGE GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
WANTING TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION.
SO IT CERTAINLY HAS BEEN VETTED
QUITE A BIT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS BUILDING, THIS BILL HAS AND
WILL, I HOPE, ALLOW US TO
ACHIEVE, AS I MENTIONED, THE
OPENING STATEMENTS, OUR CLIMATE
AND RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS. I'M
CONVINCED THAT THERE ARE, JUST A
FEW MORE AREAS THAT WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO REFINE THIS BILL IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT BALANCE
BETWEEN ACHIEVING OUR GOALS,
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT, AND
BEING ABLE TO AGAIN STAY ON
TRACK WITH OUR 2045, DEADLINES.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN HAVE A
GOOD, OPEN, HONEST CONVERSATION
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND IN THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO
AGAIN GET THIS BILL BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND PUT SOME
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY, BEFORE US
AND ONCE AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS BILL.
OKAY. YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WE DO YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS. YES. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES, PLEASE. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, ERIKA MARTIN. I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES FOR SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC, VERY HAPPY TO BE WITH
YOU TO IN SUPPORT OF AB 3238.
SGA IS SO ENCOURAGED BY THE
GROWING ACKNOWLEDGMENT AND
CONSENSUS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
THAT WE MUST BUILD ELECTRIC
TRANSMISSION, RENEWABLE
GENERATION AND OTHER ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED RATE AND SCALE. IF
WE ARE TRULY IN A CLIMATE
CRISIS, THEN WE NEED TO BEHAVE
AS IF WE ARE IN ONE. THE
EXISTING PROCESS FOR APPROVAL TO
CONSTRUCT ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE IS DUPLICATIVE,
LENGTHY AND COSTLY. BY THE TIME
A BILL GETS TO THE CPUC FOR
AUTHORITY TO BUILD IT, IT HAS
ALREADY UNDERGONE A SIGNIFICANT
FORECASTING AND PLANNING PROCESS
WITH THE CEC, WITH THE CPUC AND
SIGNIFICANTLY, AT THE CAISO, OUR
GRID OPERATOR, AND WE CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD AN ADDITIONAL 5 TO
10 YEARS OF PERMITTING AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. ON TOP OF
THAT, FOLLOWED BY YEARS OF
CONSTRUCTION BEFORE THE PROJECTS
COME ONLINE. IF WE PRESERVE THE
STATUS QUO OF PROCESS AND
PROCEDURE, WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO MOVE THE CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION FORWARD AT THE PACE
THAT WE NEED TO IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT FROM A
WARMING CLIMATE. AB 3238 IS A
MEASURED PROPOSAL THAT FOCUSES
ON THE PLACES WHERE WE'VE SEEN
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT OBSTACLES
TO PERMITTING AND APPROVAL OF
THESE PROJECTS. THE CPUC RULES
FOR PERMITTING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW ARE A FOCUS OF THE BILL,
AND THERE IS AN OPEN PROCEEDING
AT THE CPUC WHERE THIS IS
ACTIVELY BEING CONSIDERED.
HOWEVER, THE LEGISLATURE'S
LEADERSHIP IS DESPERATELY NEEDED
HERE. THE MOST RECENT STAFF
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD IN THAT
PROCEEDING FAILS TO MODIFY
PERMITTING RULES IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDES THE MEANINGFUL REVIEW
NEEDED TO ACCELERATE PERMITTING,
AND INSTEAD ADOPTS A BUSINESS AS
USUAL APPROACH WITH SOME
NONBINDING PROMISES TO MOVE
FORWARD MORE QUICKLY. AB 3238
PROPOSED REFORMS DO NOT
ELIMINATE CPUC OVERSIGHT OR THE
APPLICATION OF CEQA FOR PROJECTS
THAT REQUIRE A PERMIT TO
CONSTRUCT AT THAT AGENCY, AMONG
OTHER THINGS, THE BILL WOULD
APPLY A NINE MONTH TIMELINE FOR
THE CPUC REVIEW AND WOULD ALSO
LEVERAGE THE SIGNIFICANT
TRANSMISSION PLANNING PROCESS
THAT YOU HEARD SOME MORE ABOUT
EARLIER TODAY, IN REFERENCE TO
2292 THAT WOULD LEVERAGE THE
KAISER'S REVIEW AND PROCESS SO
THAT THE CPUC DOESN'T HAVE TO
REDO AND DUPLICATE THAT WORK
AGAIN. IN ADDITION, THE BILL
CONTAINS A NARROWLY TAILORED
CEQA EXEMPTION FOR CERTAIN
AGENCIES WHERE A UTILITY NEEDS
TO EXPAND ITS EXISTING RIGHT OF
WAY FOR ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THAT WE CAN CO-LOCATE
FACILITIES. FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN
NECESSARY. THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONDITIONS THAT WERE AMENDED
INTO THE BILL AS IT WENT THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY TO LIMIT THE PLACES
AND TIMES WHERE THAT CAN BE
APPLIED. THERE ARE SIMILAR CEQA
EXEMPTIONS THAT EXIST, FOR
EXAMPLE, ON INFILL EXEMPTIONS IN
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS INVOLVING
HOUSING, THIS WOULD NOT EXEMPT
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT
ITSELF FROM SEQUA REVIEW THAT
WOULD OCCUR AT THE CPUC OR THE
ENTIRE LINEAR PROJECT OR
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE. SITING
WOULD BE REVIEWED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. PLEASE MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN.
WE THINK THIS IS AN URGENT
PRIORITY. THIS BILL TO
ACCELERATE THE TIMELINE. AND,
ELIMINATE DUPLICATIVE REVIEW. WE
THINK IT'S A MODEST PROPOSAL,
BUT WE ALSO THINK IT'S NECESSARY
BECAUSE OF THE SCALE OF THE
BUILD OUT OF TRANSMISSION THAT
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE. SO
WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS, VALERIE
CHIRLA ALEJO'S, PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI, ELLEN
BRITTINGHAM, ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY POWER AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, ANDREW WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MELISSA CORTEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THAT'S IMPRESSED WITH
ADVANCED ENERGY UNITED IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LEAH BARROS
ON BEHALF OF INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SUPPORT
HERE IN ROOM 1200. SEEING NONE.
LET'S LOOK AT MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON. THERE ARE
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SO
DO WE EACH GET TWO MINUTES?
OKAY, GREAT. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS KIM DELFINO, AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY. LET ME
START OUT BY SAYING THAT MY
CLIENTS SUPPORT EFFICIENCIES TO
BRING ON TRANSMISSION QUICKLY.
WE KNOW HOW IMPERATIVE IT IS FOR
OUR STATE AND PLANET TO
TRANSITION TO CLEAN ENERGY AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. HOWEVER,
EFFICIENCIES SHOULD NOT EQUAL
WEAKENING CORE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS. WHILE AB 3238 HAS
BEEN AMENDED ALONG THE WAY AND
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS. AND THERE ARE
PARTS OF THE BILL THAT EMBODY
SMART POLICY, SUCH AS USING THE
DRAFT CEQA DOCUMENT INSTEAD OF A
PROPONENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENT. THERE ARE STILL
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT WE
CAN CORE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS. IN FACT, IN BASED
ON MY 15 YEARS OF WORKING ON
TRANSMISSION AND ENERGY PROJECTS
, I BELIEVE THAT SOME OF THESE
PROPOSED CHANGES RUN THE RISK OF
MAKING PROJECTS MORE
CONTROVERSIAL, MORE COSTLY, AND
MORE TIME CONSUMING BECAUSE THEY
PROMOTE A HEAD IN THE SAND
APPROACH TO PROJECT DEVELOPMENT,
SPECIFICALLY, AB 3238 WILL
EXEMPT THE EXPANSION OF ANY
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAYS.
UTILITIES, GAS, BROADBAND ON ALL
STATE LANDS, STATE PARKS, STATE
WILDLIFE AREAS, STATE LANDS
COMMISSION LANDS. THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS MADE NOTE OF THIS AND
PROPOSED PERHAPS NARROWING IT,
BUT I WOULD SAY EVEN EXISTING
TRANSMISSION LINES IN STATE
PARKS ALONE, THAT'S A, 100. NO,
275 MILES OF TRANSMISSION ALONE,
JUST IN STATE PARKS FOR EXISTING
TRANSMISSION. AB 3238 WOULD
CHANGE THE PUC SEQUA PROCESS TO
DELIBERATELY CONSTRAIN THE
REVIEW BY TRUSTEE AGENCIES FROM
ANALYZING THE FULL EXTENT OF
PROJECTS, IMPACTS ON NATURAL
RESOURCES. IT ALSO PUTS IN PLACE
A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
THE PUC CAN USE A STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDING CONSIDERATIONS, WHICH
MEANS THAT WHEN THE DEVELOPER
STARTS THEIR SEQUA PROCESS, THEY
ALREADY HAVE THIS PRESUMPTION
THAT THEY CAN OVERRIDE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS. THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE TO PUT IN SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE OTHERWISE. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE URGE THAT THIS BILL
IS AMENDED TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS. AND THANK YOU. AND
RIGHT NOW, URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. MY NAME IS BREA
FORDHAM. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ANZA-BORREGO
FOUNDATION, THE OFFICIAL PARTNER
TO ANZA-BORREGO DESERT STATE
PARK, I'D LIKE TO FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
FOR HIS AWARENESS OF THE
DELICATE BALANCE BETWEEN OUR
NEEDS AND THE ENVIRONMENT. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. AND I DO
HOPE THAT WE CAN COME TO A
MEETING PLACE ON THIS, I'D LIKE
TO ASK, HOW MANY OF YOU ATTENDED
SIXTH GRADE CAMP, ENJOYED
CAMPING WITH YOUR PARENTS OR
TODAY, TAKE YOUR OWN FAMILIES TO
VISIT THE INCREDIBLE PROTECTED
NATURAL LANDSCAPES OF
CALIFORNIA. NOW, HOW MANY OF YOU
RECALL THESE LIFE CHANGING
MEMORIES BEING UNDER THE EERIE
HUM OF A TRANSMISSION TOWER, THE
HEIGHT OF A 20 STORY BUILDING?
IF AB 3238 PASSES, AS IS THE
UNADULTERATED NATURE EXPERIENCES
YOU HAVE HAD ACCESS TO, WILL
UNNECESSARY BE PUT AT RISK OF
BEING DESTROYED AS THE BILL IS
WRITTEN TODAY, THE EXPANSION OF
EXISTING RIGHTS OF WAY ARE
EXEMPT FROM SEQUA IN
ANZA-BORREGO DESERT STATE PARK.
HUNDREDS OF MILES OF EXISTING
RIGHTS OF WAYS WILL BECOME THE
PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE FOR
HUNDREDS OF 200 FOOT TOWERS,
PERMANENTLY SCARRING OUR
CAMPGROUNDS, OUR HIKING TRAILS,
OUR SACRED CULTURAL PRESERVES,
ENDANGERED WILDLIFE HABITAT,
DARK NIGHT SKIES AND MORE.
NOTHING WILL BE PROTECTED. THIS
IS NOT HYPOTHETICAL. CAISO HAS
APPROVED A 500 KV LINE SET TO
CUT DIRECTLY THROUGH THE
LARGEST, MOST BIODIVERSE,
DESIGNATED WILDERNESS PARK LAND
IN THE STATE. NOW, WITHOUT
MEANINGFUL ENVIRONMENTAL OR
CUMULATIVE IMPACT REVIEW, WE SET
ASIDE WILDERNESS IN PERPETUITY
FOR OUR UNBORN GENERATIONS.
PERPETUITY IS A LONG TIME. IT
SHOULD NEVER BE SACRIFICED
BECAUSE IT IS THE WAY OF THE
QUICKEST, MOST DIRECT, OR LEAST
EXPENSIVE. THERE IS ANOTHER WAY.
THERE ARE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ALLOW FOR LESS IMPACT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND IN LESS TIME,
WHILE STILL MEETING THE NEEDS AS
OFFERED IN OUR MATERIALS, AS
SUBMITTED AND SUPPORTED BY AB
3246 AND SB 1006, I THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING AND CONSIDERING
THE RISKS THAT 3238 POSES TO THE
DECADES OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION WE HAVE INTENTIONALLY
PUT IN PLACE. WE ALSO THANK THE
AUTHORS STAFF FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS, AND WE HOPE THIS BILL
CAN BE AMENDED FURTHER TO
EXCLUDE PARKS FROM THE CEQA
EXEMPTION. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ABIGAIL SCHMIDT, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED, POSITION. THANK YOU.
WELL, HELLO, JACOB EVANS, ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB,
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL, PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE, SURFRIDER
AND CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, ALEX
LOOMER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND, IN A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION, UNLESS THE BILL IS
AMENDED TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE SOLELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
TERMS OF THE MULTI-PARTY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT, THE CPUC
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
BORREGO SPRINGS CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, BORREGO SPRINGS
SPRINGS COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTER, BORREGO SPRINGS MALL,
BORREGO SPRINGS YOUTH AND SENIOR
CENTER, BORREGO VILLAGE
ASSOCIATION, THÀNH AND NINE
OTHER BUSINESSES AND 37
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE BORREGO
SPRINGS COMMUNITY. IN OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
ROOM? SEEING NONE, I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SENATOR STERN
, THANK YOU, MEMBER, FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. MY
QUESTION IS NOT ABOUT BORREGO
SPRINGS, ALTHOUGH I KNOW WE
HEARD FROM BORREGO SPRINGS,
BECAUSE THE BILL SUNSETS IN, I
THINK 2030, I THINK THE WAY IT'S
DESIGNED, I WANTED TO GET A
SENSE OF WHAT THINGS COULD LOOK
LIKE IN, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON TERRITORY, I KNOW WE
HEARD A LOT FROM SDG AND E, AND
I'M SORT OF TAKING FROM THE,
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
THERE'S, THERE'S A SENSITIVITY
OR CONFLICT AROUND THAT, I
GUESS, ANZA-BORREGO PARK AREA.
BUT, IS THERE DO WE HAVE A SENSE
YET EITHER FROM WHAT ISO IS
APPROVED OR FROM WHAT EDISON'S
PROPOSED, HOW THIS COULD WORK ON
STATE LANDS IN THEIR TERRITORY.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN
ANSWER. MAYBE I'M GOING TO ASK
OUR MAIN. THEY HAVE TO COME UP
AND ANSWER SITE SPECIFIC
QUESTION. SO AS AS YOU NOTED, I
AM FROM SDG AND E, I THINK WE
WOULD. SO WE'RE NOT IMMEDIATELY
FAMILIAR WITH PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY PLANNED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON'S TERRITORY. I
THINK ONE THING THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE IS THE PROSPECTIVE
NATURE OF THE EXEMPTION FOR
FUTURE PROJECTS, AND THAT THE
CAISO TRANSMISSION PLANNING
PROCESS WILL, APPROVE NEW
PROJECTS EVERY YEAR. SO IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO PREDICT THAT,
AS FAR AS EXISTING PROJECTS,
SINCE IT'S NOT, CURRENTLY
APPLICABLE AND I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THOSE PROJECTS, I DON'T
THINK I CAN GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC
ANSWER THERE, BUT PERHAPS WE CAN
, WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL THERE HERE,
THOUGH. YEAH. I'M SORRY. YEAH.
MAYBE YOU LOVE TO HEAR FROM
THEM. YEAH WELL, APOLOGIES. NO
OFFENSE. NO. YEAH. NO PROBLEM. I
DON'T KNOW, ANDREW. I DON'T WANT
TO PUT YOU ON THE SPOT HERE, BUT
I'M GOING TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT. JUST WONDERING, WHAT'S
PLANNED BECAUSE THIS WOULD APPLY
TO, PROSPECTIVE PROJECTS,
INCLUDING THOSE THAT ISOS
ALREADY APPROVED. RIGHT. YEAH. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION,
SENATOR. I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU WITH THAT
INFORMATION. I DON'T HAVE IT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. OKAY.
SORRY. THAT'S ALL RIGHT. YEAH
BUT WE'LL WORK ON IT AND GET IT
TO YOU. OKAY? ALL RIGHT. I'VE
ACTUALLY I'VE ALREADY PUT IN THE
QUESTION AND I HOPE. OKAY.
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NO,
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR BECKER, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS. I
WOULD JUST LOVE TO HEAR YOUR. DO
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON SORT OF
THE KIND OF OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
AND, CORRESPONDINGLY SORT OF THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL? WELL, IT'S
BEEN SAID THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD
FOCUS JUST ON THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. RIGHT AND NOT THE
MORE THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
PUT OUT A DRAFT, TWO WEEKS AGO.
AND WHAT WAS AGREED TO PUT
FORWARD IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT BY, BY A HANDFUL OF
FOLKS. AND THE DRAFT THAT ROLLED
OUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS, IS NOT
REFLECTIVE OF THE AGREEMENT THAT
WAS PUT FORWARD AT THE CPUC. AND
SO EVEN IF WE WENT IN THAT
DIRECTION, IT DOESN'T DO TO WHAT
FOLKS EXPECTED THE CPC TO ACT
ON. AND SO SOMEONE USED THE WORD
THE STATUS QUO EARLIER. THE
STATUS QUO WILL NOT ALLOW US TO
MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY TO MEET OUR
2045 GOALS AND OBJECTIVES. AND
IF AND IF WE REMAIN ON THAT SAME
PATH, THEN WE SHOULD JUST START
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO MEET THOSE
GOALS AND BEGIN ADJUSTING OUR
POLICIES AND OUR EFFORTS IN THAT
PARTICULAR MANNER. RIGHT. IT'S
KIND OF A FALSE NARRATIVE TO
TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS GOALS IN
OUR ENERGY SPACE AND OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND ALL OF THIS GREAT
THING, WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THE
TRANSITION AND, YOU KNOW, RIGHT,
IT IT'S NOT HAPPENING UNLESS WE
ARE FAR MORE AGGRESSIVE WITH
BUILDING OUT THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
TO BE ABLE TO PROCURE THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THE OPTIONS THAT
WE HAVE TO THIS PARTICULAR
CONVERSATION AS WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND CREATE THESE TYPES
OF EXEMPTIONS WITH EXISTING
RIGHT OF WAY THAT WE'VE ALREADY
VETTED THROUGH. AND THERE STILL
HAS TO BE SOME KIND OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. THERE OR
WE CAN TALK ABOUT NEW RIGHT OF
WAY, AND THAT CREATES A WHOLE
OTHER CONVERSATION THAT THAT'S
NOT THE QUESTION AT HAND, I
MENTIONED TO YOU IN MY COMMENTS,
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH FOUR POLICY
COMMITTEES. AND IF YOU LOOK AT
WHERE WE STARTED WITH THE BILL
AND WHERE AT TODAY, I'VE
DESCRIBED SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS
THAT ARE BEING MADE TODAY AS
IDEOLOGICAL, AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO CRAFT POLICY AND
AMEND IT INTO A BILL TO ADDRESS
IDEOLOGICAL AND PHILOSOPHICAL
ISSUES. WE'RE AT A CROSSROAD
WHERE YOU, ME, US, INCLUDING
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION. ARE WE REAL ABOUT
WANTING TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES? AND SO WE HAVE A
POTENTIAL PATH HERE. AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO, YOU KNOW, CREATE A
SITUATION, AS IT WAS DESCRIBED
BY OUR FRIENDS AT BORREGO, TO
RUIN, YOU KNOW, THE MEMORIES OF
CHILDHOOD VISITATIONS TO THE
STATE PARKS. WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS AS IT RELATES
TO THIS EXISTENTIAL THREAT THAT
WE REFER TO AS CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT'S REALLY THE QUESTION AT
HAND. AND IF THERE IS A
DIFFERENT AND A BETTER WAY OF
GOING ABOUT IT, I'M HAPPY TO
HEAR HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT.
AND WE'VE HAD FOUR STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS AND HAPPY TO HAVE FOUR
MORE, IF YOU'VE GOT SOME POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS, IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL RAIL GUARDS SAYING
VIÆT, YOU KNOW, GUARDS TO PUT IN
THE BILL AS IT RELATES TO THIS
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY SEQUA
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING,
I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT IT.
THERE'LL BE HOPEFULLY ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY, ANOTHER COMMITTEE,
TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION. I HOPE,
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, THAT ALSO
ADD SOME MORE, YOU KNOW, OPTIONS
, ENTITIES TO CREATE SOME
CERTAINTY TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT, BUT ALSO KEEP US ON
THE PATH OF ACCELERATION. WE USE
THE WORD ACCELERATION WHEN IT
COMES TO PROCURING OUR ENERGY.
WE NEED TO ACCELERATE THE
BUILDOUT OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL TO MEET THOSE
OBJECTIVES. SO, SENATOR BECKER,
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO TAKE A BALANCED APPROACH.
I HOPE THAT THE REPUTATION OF
THE WORK HERE AND MY TENURE IN
THE LEGISLATURE, SPEAKS TO OUR,
DESIRE TO PUSH GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SPACE, BUT ALSO AT THE SAME
TIME, BE PRAGMATIC WHEN IT COMES
TO GETTING FROM POINT A TO POINT
B AND MAKING SURE THAT IT'S DONE
IN A WAY IN WHICH WE ARE,
KEEPING IN MIND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED FROM THIS
ISSUE OF CLIMATE. WELL, I'D SAY
THAT THAT REPUTATION DOES MEAN A
LOT TO ME. AND I KNOW YOU'VE
WORKED HARD. I YOU KNOW, AND
MYSELF, SENATOR PADILLA, OTHERS
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS,
FINDING THE RIGHT BALANCE AROUND
THE STREAMLINING AND PERMITTING.
SO WE GET THINGS BUILT WHILE
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT. SO I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING HARD TO
FIND THAT BALANCE. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY AND,
SUPPORT YOU AS YOU GO AHEAD AND
CAN KEEP WORKING ON FINDING THAT
BALANCE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
MEMBERS? NO NO, I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR, DIRECTLY,
BECAUSE I WENT THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE FIRSTHAND OVER 15
YEARS AGO WORKING FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND TRYING TO
BUILD THE TRI TIP TO TEHACHAPI
POWER LINES AND A PROJECT THAT
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL FRIENDS
ADVOCATED FOR. BUT WHEN IT CAME
DOWN TO BUILDING THE
TRANSMISSION LINES, THEY WERE
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED, REGARDLESS
OF WHERE THEY DID, WHERE WE
PLANNED ON PUTTING THEM, THEY
WERE SEEING NO. THE SAME THING
HAPPENED WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC ON THE SUNRISE POWER
LINE. BOTH OF THOSE PROJECTS
WERE DELAYED ALMOST FIVE YEARS
AND ADDED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
THE COST. AT THE SAME TIME, WE
SET ALL THESE ARBITRARY GOALS OF
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THIS
RENEWABLE POWER, BUT WE'RE
FAILING TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NECESSARY
TO DELIVER THE POWER TO WHERE
IT'S NEEDED. SO THIS PROTECTION
ENVIRONMENT I'M VERY CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THE INTENTIONS ARE, IT HAS
ALL THOSE, CHECKPOINTS. ALL THIS
DOES IS STREAMLINES THE PROCESS.
AND WE USE THESE SAME PROCESSES
TO BUILD FOOTBALL STADIUMS AND
ARENAS IN CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY
WE TRUNCATE SECRET PROCESSES.
AND THIS IS ALL THAT THIS BILL
DOES. IT HAS ALL THE SAFEGUARDS
THAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WITH
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND I THINK
IT'S A COMMON SENSE MEASURE. AND
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
HERE IN THIS AREA. THANK YOU.
WE'RE SEEKING A WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST TO SAY THAT WE
CONTINUE THE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION, WITH BOTH THE
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL AND I SINCERELY MEAN THAT
WE WANT TO GET THIS RIGHT AND, I
HOPE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO GET AN
AYE VOTE HERE AND, AND GET THIS
BILL TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN. WE HAVE
A Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. I'LL JUST
STATE THE AMENDMENTS, CLARIFY
THAT THE ELIGIBILITY IS FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE WITHIN THE
UTILITIES RIGHT OF WAY. THIS IS
NO NEW AREA. IT'S IN THE CURRENT
RIGHT OF WAYS. AND MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT APPLY
TO PROJECTS RELATED TO THE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION OF
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY PROJECTS
AND TRANSMISSION FACILITIES
NEEDED FOR THOSE PROJECTS
LOCATED IN THE COASTAL ZONE AND
SUBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
SB 286 BY PRO TEM MCGUIRE, LAST
YEAR, WHERE THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS THE LEAD AND LEAD
AGENCY ON THOSE PROJECTS. SO
IT'S NO CONFLICT THERE. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLE
AMENDED, AS STATED, AMENDED TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY, DO PASS
TO BE AMENDED IN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. DALLI DALLI. AYE. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER AYE. BECKER.
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DODD DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
LEMON MIN. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. SATO SKINNER.
STERN WILK 11 ZERO. THAT MEASURE
HAS 11 VOTES. IT'S OUT. WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. NOW, YOUR
FINAL ITEM. AB 3246. THANK YOU.
ON TRANSMISSION, THEME OF THE
DAY. THIS ACTUALLY, WITHOUT
HAVING TO BUILD TRANSMISSION,
WHICH IS VERY COSTLY, TIMELY.
THIS UTILIZES TECHNOLOGIES TO BE
ABLE TO ENHANCE THE ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE EXISTING LINES. THIS IS
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS USED IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, INCREASING
RELIABILITY, SAFETY AND
EFFICIENCY. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. IS MR.
VIJAYAN WHITE YOUR CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS JOHN WHITE WITH CLEAN
POWER CAMPAIGN ADVANCED RE
CONDUCTING ALLOWS US TO GET MORE
POWER FLOWING THROUGH THE
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY. AND THIS
IS A BILL THAT PUTS A DEFINITION
OF ADVANCED RE CONDUCTING INTO
STATE LAW BASED ON SUCCESS IN
OTHER STATES SUCH AS MONTANA. AS
WELL AS PROVIDE A REGULATORY
INCENTIVE THROUGH A TIER THREE
ADVICE LETTER FOR THE PUC TO
EXPEDITE THE APPROVAL OF THESE
PROJECTS, WHICH WILL COST MORE
UP FRONT BUT SAVE MONEY OVER THE
LIFE AND THE OPERATION. WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MY NAME
IS DAN JACOBSON WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. IT WILL SAVE RATES,
IT'LL SAVE THE RATEPAYER MONEY
AND INCREASE RELIABILITY TO THE
GRID AND ALLOW US TO BRING MORE
RENEWABLES ON FASTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS ELLEN
BRITTINGHAM. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
POWER. OUR LETTER CAME IN AFTER
THE DEADLINE BUT WANTED TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR MEMBERS EDSON
PEREZ WITH ADVANCED ENERGY
UNITED IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. LEAH BARROS,
ON BEHALF OF INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON, AARON KUNZ
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISORS, ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF
OF SAN JOSE CLEAN ENERGY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MELISSA
CORTEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING, REBECCA
MARCUS, REPRESENTING THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO, GOOD
EVENING, VALERIE CHIRLA ALEJO'S,
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY. WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL, BUT WANTED
TO RESPECTFULLY JUST GO ON
RECORD THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT AN ISSUE. ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
RAISED THERE, AS WE JUST
DISCUSSED IN THE PREVIOUS BILL,
THERE'S AN ACTIVE PROCEEDING
GOING ON, ON THESE TOPICS AND WE
ARE HOPING THAT WE CAN COME TO
AN AGREEMENT TO HAVE MORE DATE
ALIGNMENT ON THE CONCLUSION OF
THE CPUC S WORK AND THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR HAVE BEEN, PRODUCTIVE,
AND WE HOPE TO RESOLVE THAT
ISSUE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM 1200? WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS, WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR EGGMAN. WE
HAVE A Dð PASS THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. AND
ASSEMBLYMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I'M DONE. THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
HE'S DONE. SECRETARY, CALL THE
ROLL. BRADFORD AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. DALLI DALLI NOT VOTING.
ASHBY. HI. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO I DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
I. EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE
GROVE. NOT VOTING. LIMÓN. MINH
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. SKINNER. STERN
AYE. STERN. AYE. WILK. ALL
RIGHT. TEN ZERO. THAT MEASURE
HAS TEN VOTES. IT'S OUT.
CONGRATULATIONS. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
ADD ON. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA AND WE'RE GOING TO
START OUT WITH FILE ITEM, AB
FILE ITEM ONE AB 691. WE SEEK AN
AYE MOTION ON THAT MEASURE. NO
WE, WELL, SHE'S NOT HERE. I'M
NOT HERE YET. NO. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON FILE ITEM ONE? IT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE. OH, IT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, I WAS
GONE. YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T. I
GOT. WE'LL OPEN THE ROLL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AT THIS TIME TO
ADD ON TO, FILE ITEM ONE, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BELIEVE
WE'D BE DONE. OKAY. I DON'T. NOT
HERE YET. WE'RE JUST GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE Ó. I WANT TO GET
THROUGH. OKAY, AB 691, BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. GONZALEZ LIMÓN.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
SKINNER WILK. NÓ. WILK. NÓ AND
THREE. TEN. THREE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FOUR.
OPEN THE ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. AB 2292 PETRIE-NORRIS. CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. DALLI NOT VOTING.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. NOT
VOTING. LIMÓN. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO SKINNER. WILK WILK. NOT
VOTING 10 TO 0. THAT MEASURE
HAS, TEN VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM FIVE, AB
2815. OKAY DO PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATE CURRENT VOTE. TEN
ZERO CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
GONZALEZ. LIMÓN RUBIO. RUBIO.
AYE SATO. SKINNER. WILK. HI
WILK. AYE. 13 ZERO OKAY. MEASURE
HAS 13 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM SIX. AB
1826. DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TWO. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE GONZALEZ. LIMÓN NEUMAN.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
SKINNER WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO. 9393
AB AND AB 1834 FOLLOWING SEVEN
BY GARCIA. 1834 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 11 ZERO. GONZALEZ
LIMÓN RUBIO. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
SKINNER. WILK WILK. AYE 13 ZERO
13 ZERO. AND NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHT. AB 3238 DO PASS
TO BE AMENDED. AN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY CURRENT VOTE 11 ZERO
GONZALEZ LIMÓN SATO. SKINNER.
STERN OAN. WILK. Ã. WILK I 12
ZERO 12 ZERO. NOW FILE ITEM NINE
AB 3246. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE TEN
ZERO. GONZALEZ LIMÓN SATO.
SKINNER WILK WILK I 11 ZERO 11
ZERO. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE OUT TO FILE ITEM 11 AB 2537
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN READY. WELL, THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR,
STAFF AND SUPPORTERS. THAT ARE
HERE TODAY. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2537, THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT IN OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY ACT. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE NUMEROUS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR
MONTHS IN AN EFFORT TO GET IT
RIGHT. I DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND BELIEVE THEY WILL
BE TAKEN IN SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. SO AS YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA'S ESTABLISHED
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AND OUR
PROGRESS TOWARDS THESE GOALS
BENEFITS NOT ONLY HUMAN
COMMUNITIES, BUT FRAGILE
ECOSYSTEMS AND VITAL
BIODIVERSITY ON THE LAND, IN THE
AIR AND IN THE OCEAN. AMONG
THESE GOALS IS THE REQUIREMENT
TO TRANSITION TO 100% RENEWABLE
AND ZERO CARBON ENERGY RESOURCES
BY 2045, WITH 25GW, OR ENOUGH
POWER FOR ABOUT 25 MILLION HOMES
COMING FROM OFFSHORE WIND.
ENERGY PLANNING FOR OFFSHORE
WIND ENERGY IS WELL UNDERWAY IN
CALIFORNIA, STARTING AS FAR BACK
AS 2016. IN 2022, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AWARDED FIVE LEASES
IN FEDERAL WATERS OFF THE COAST
OF OUR STATE TO ALONG NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THREE ALONG THE
CENTRAL COAST. IN JUNE 2023, THE
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY LEASES WERE
EXECUTED, AND IN JANUARY 2024,
THE CEC RELEASED CALIFORNIA'S
OFFSHORE WIND STRATEGIC PLAN.
LEASEHOLDERS ARE CURRENTLY
MOVING INTO THE SURVEYING,
PLANNING AND PERMITTING STAGES
OF DEVELOPMENT, SO AS OFFSHORE
WIND ENERGY MOVES FORWARD IN
WATERS ALONG THE NORTH AND
CENTRAL COASTS, AND MY DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY, EXTENSIVE INPUT
FROM INPUT FROM AND INTERACTION
WITH LOCAL TRIBES AND
COMMUNITIES IS NEEDED.
HISTORICALLY, WE KNOW THAT
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE HOSTED
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN BURDENED WITH HARMFUL
IMPACTS. AND SO TODAY WE LOOK TO
DO BETTER FOR OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY PROJECTS PLACED ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S PRISTINE AND
FRAGILE COASTLINE. WE ALL AGREE
THAT UPLIFTING TRIBAL AND
COMMUNITY VOICES IS CRITICAL,
BOTH DURING THE PLANNING AND
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENTS
PROCESSES, SO WITH THAT SAID,
I'VE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM
LOCAL COMMUNITY SUCH AS SMALL
TRIBES AND CITIES THAT THERE
HAVE THAT THERE IS A GAP IN
RESOURCES PREVENTING THEM FROM
ADEQUATELY PARTICIPATING IN
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY PLANNING
AND COMMUNITY BENEFIT
CONVERSATIONS. AND I'LL JUST SAY
THIS I THINK WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THESE SITUATIONS. IS
THAT TRUE ENGAGEMENT OFTEN
NECESSITATES POSSESSING IN-DEPTH
KNOWLEDGE, INFORMATION AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH NEW AND
COMPLEX SUBJECTS AND PROJECTS
SUCH AS IN THE CASE OF OFFSHORE
WIND ENERGY DEVELOPMENT. SO AB
2537, THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY ACT
CREATES A SOLUTION BY
ESTABLISHING AN OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY COMMUNITY CAPACITY
FUNDING GRANT ACCOUNT THAT WILL
PROVIDE GRANTS TO LOCAL TRIBES
AND COMMUNITIES. THESE GRANTS
WILL ENHANCE THE ABILITY TO
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN THE
PLANNING, AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
BENEFITS. PROCESS THESE SO THAT
LOCAL TRIBES AND COMMUNITIES ARE
MORE SECURE IN THEIR ABILITY TO
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD AND COME
TO FAIR AGREEMENTS. I WANT TO
THANK OUR SPONSORS, THIS
COMMITTEE AND OUR STAKEHOLDER
PARTNERS FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT
AND JOINING ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ALEXIS SODERMAN FROM
BRIGHTLINE DEFENSE PROJECT.
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD EVENING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M ALEXIS
GUTTERMAN WITH BRIGHTLINE
DEFENSE. WE ARE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
BEEN DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THE
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS, AND WE SEE IT AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO SUPPORT A
CLEANER, HEALTHIER AND MORE
RELIABLE GRID, AND ALSO,
IMPORTANTLY, TO LIFT THE
POLLUTION BURDEN OFF OF LOW
INCOME AND FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES. IN OUR WORK, WE
HAVE HEARD DIRECTLY FROM
COMMUNITY AND TRIBAL LEADERS
LIVING NEAR PROPOSED OFFSHORE
WIND PROJECTS THAT THEY ARE
CURIOUS, EXCITED AND INTERESTED
IN ENGAGING IN AND SHAPING
DEVELOPMENT. BUT ALSO THAT THEY
LACK THE RESOURCES AND THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO ENGAGE.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM. THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S 525 OFFSHORE
WIND STRATEGIC PLAN HIGHLIGHTS
THAT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IS
CRITICAL FOR OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT. ABSENT RESOURCES
FOR MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT,
CALIFORNIA RUNS THE RISK OF
ENCOUNTERING ISSUES, DELAYS OR
OTHERWISE IRRESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT. TO ADDRESS THIS, AB
2537 WOULD UNLOCK MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND TRIBES TO MEANINGFULLY
ENGAGE IN THE OFFSHORE WIND
PROJECT PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. FOR EXAMPLE, A
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY MEMBER COULD
USE THESE RESOURCES TO ATTEND A
WORKSHOP OR A MEETING, RESPOND
TO A TECHNICAL COMMENT,
OPPORTUNITY, AND PARTICIPATE IN
KEY DECISION MAKING PROCESSES.
THIS FUNDING WOULD COME FROM A
FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTION FROM
CALIFORNIA OFFSHORE WIND LEASE
HOLDERS FOR THREE YEARS AFTER
THE LEASES ARE SIGNED, IMPORTANT
TO NOTE LEASEHOLDERS ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTION, REFLECTING HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE A
COMMUNITY LED AND COMMUNITY
RESOURCE PROCESS FOR THE SUCCESS
OF OFFSHORE WIND. IN SOME, AB
2537 WOULD PUT CALIFORNIA A
MAJOR STEP AHEAD ON EQUITABLE
AND JUST CLEAN ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT. THEREFORE
BRIGHTLINE IS A PROUD SPONSOR
AND WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION. PLEASE
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CARMEN GUZMAN, ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. JACOB
EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. REBECCA MARCUS, ON BEHALF
OF THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT JORDAN
CURLEY ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
AND NRDC IN SUPPORT. MANDY
ISAACS LEE HERE FOR CAL CHAMBER
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
NOW LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE
NOW, WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SENATOR DALI,
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION? YEAH IF
I MAY. I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED ON, SO THE
LEASEHOLDERS, WE'RE GOING TO TAX
THE LEASE HOLDERS AND THAT MONEY
IS GOING TO GO TO ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY OFFSHORE WIND.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL BASICALLY
DOES. WELL. IT SETS UP A
REQUIRED FUND SO THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN BETTER ENGAGE IN
THE CONVERSATION AND THE
PLANNING PROCESSES AROUND
PROJECTS THAT WILL DIRECTLY
AFFECT THEIR COMMUNITIES, SO
THAT THEY CAN BETTER BE PARTNERS
IN GOING THROUGH THIS
CONVERSATION. SO IT WOULD SET UP
A REQUIRED FUND FOR THAT. AND
TYPICALLY THE FUNDS WOULD COME
FOR WHEN THEY DO A SEQUA OR NEPA
PROJECT. THOSE, THOSE APPLICANTS
WOULD PAY, THEY WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO MITIGATE IF THERE
WAS IMPACTS. BUT BECAUSE WE'VE
PASSED LEGISLATION THAT SAYS
WE'RE JUST GOING TO GO DO WIND
GENERATION ON THE OCEAN, THERE
IS NO THE APPLICANT. BASICALLY
THESE THESE LEASE HOLDERS. SO
THIS IS REQUIRED TAX ON THOSE
LEASE HOLDERS TO ACTUALLY HELP
ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY ON THE
IMPACTS, NOT NECESSARILY ON THE
IMPACTS, BUT ON THE PLANNING
PROCESS SO THAT THEY HAVE MORE
CAPACITY TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION. THÀNH. SO IT'S NOT
IN EXCHANGE NOT A COMMUNITY
BENEFITS, NOT A MITIGATION THÀNH
IT'S TO HELP BUILD CAPACITY SO
THAT SMALLER TRIBES AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
ENGAGE IN THE CONVERSATION. THIS
IS JUST A PROCESS I'VE NOT SEEN
BEFORE. TYPICALLY YOU HAVE AN
APPLICANT DOES A SEQUA REQUIRED
LAW THROUGH SEQUA. WHATEVER
THOSE IMPACTS ARE, ARE MITIGATED
OR NOT MITIGATED. ONE OF THE
TWO. SO ANYWAY, OKAY, I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW
IT'S GOING TO WORK. SO AND THERE
AND THEN THIS WILL EVENTUALLY
GET PASSED ON TO THE RATEPAYERS
AT SOME POINT SOMEBODY THAT HAS
TO PAY FOR THE BILL. WHICH WILL
BE THE RATEPAYERS, I'M ASSUMING
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I THINK
IT'S TOO EARLY TO SAY THAT PIECE
OF IT. I MEAN, WE'RE REALLY IN
THE VERY, VERY BEGINNING STAGES
IS WHERE LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
THESE REALLY VÆ, FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD, GINORMOUS PROJECTS.
THEY'RE NEW PROJECTS. THEY WANT
TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THE
CONVERSATION, ENGAGE IN THE
PLANNING, BE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THEY MIGHT WANT TO ASK FOR IN A
COMMUNITY BENEFITS CONVERSATION,
BUT FEEL LIKE AND IN REALITY
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE CAPACITY
K¾T TO KNOW HOW TO DO THAT OR
HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO KNOW HOW
TO DO THAT. AND SO THE REQUIRED
FUND FOR TIME. IT'S A TIME
LIMITED REQUIRED FUND WOULD HELP
THEM HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
THAT. SO I'LL GET TO SEE THIS
BILL AGAIN. AND IT'S GOING TO
NATURAL RESOURCES I BELIEVE.
RIGHT. SO I'LL DO A LITTLE MORE
WORK ON IT. I JUST WANT TO YOU
KNOW, THIS HAS BEEN MY CRITICISM
OF THE NGUYEN IS THAT THIS IS
HUGE IMPACTS. YOU'RE RIGHT. A
VERY HUGE IMPACTS FOR SOME VERY
NARROW COMMUNITIES. SAN DIEGO
PORT AND, HUMBOLDT PORT FOR
SURE. AND THEN THE COMMUNITIES
ALONG THE COAST, AND I BROUGHT
THAT OUT WHEN WE DID THE
LEGISLATION, I THINK IT WAS
MAGUIRE'S 286 BILL THAT SAID,
WE'RE JUST GOING TO GO DO THIS
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIGURE IT
OUT, WHICH IS NOT TYPICALLY HOW
WE DO THINGS. FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING TO SEE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FOLKS JUST COME
AND SAY, YEAH, LET'S DO THIS.
WELL, THAT'S THERE'S A REASON,
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROCESS IS BACKWARDS. AND SO WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE MONEY TO FIND
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON. SO I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED. I'LL READ A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN YOUR BILL,
GET TO SEE IT IN A LAYOFF TODAY
AND HOPEFULLY UNDERSTAND AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS HUGE,
HUGE 25GW. THAT'S 25,000MW
COMING OFF THE OCEAN, WHICH IS
HUGE, TO TWO PORTS, MAINLY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT THERE'S SO MANY CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW IT'S GOING TO WORK
WITH ALL THE IMPACTS AT THOSE
TWO SITES. AND THEN FOR THE REST
OF CALIFORNIA TRANSMISSION
ISSUES, WHICH WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH TODAY. SO THANK YOU. AND IF
I MAY JUST CLARIFY, THIS IS
REALLY FOR THE OFFSHORE WIND
CALL AREAS. SO THIS BILL DOESN'T
REALLY ADDRESS, THE PORT SIDE OF
THINGS. THEY NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THOUGH. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
BY MEMBERS? I THINK WE HAD A
MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST I, I
WOULD SAY THAT AB 2537 DOES
RECOGNIZE THAT CALIFORNIA IS ON
A PATH TO CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
AND WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT ALONG
THIS PATH, WE DO NEED TO UPLIFT
VOICES OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES,
VOICES OF TRIBE, OF TRIBES, AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ENGAGE IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY, WE HAVE Dð PASS TO
BE AMENDED IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER, AND I WILL JUST
CLARIFY THOSE FOUR AMENDMENTS,
CLARIFY THAT THE CEC MUST
DEVELOP THE GUIDELINES VIA A
PUBLIC PROCESS WITH PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS, CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE
RELATED TO TRIBAL PARTICIPATION.
CLARIFY THE FUNDING COLLECTED AS
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL IS SUBJECT
TO THE DONATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND ADD A DATE BY
WHEN THE CDC MUST ANNUALLY
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. WOULD
YOU AGREE TO. ALL CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
AB 2537. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. DALY ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE. DODD
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GONZALEZ EGGMAN.
AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE. LIMÓN.
LIMÓN AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO SKINNER. STERN. AYE
STERN. AYE. WILK. ALL RIGHT. 11
ONE. THAT VOTE HAS 11 VOTES IN
FAVOR. ONE OPPOSED. WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW, MEMBERS WILL GO
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA
AGAIN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. AT THIS POINT, AND HOPEFULLY
THOSE OTHER MEMBERS WILL MAKE
THEIR WAY TO THE COMMITTEE,
BECAUSE WE'LL BE GAVELING OUT
SHORTLY. SO CAN I JUST CALL ME
NOW? THANK YOU. SO MUCH. OH, I'M
SORRY, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT YOU
WANTED ME TO START. OKAY I'M
SORRY. OKAY AB 691 TÍNH DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
TEN THREE. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO. GONZALEZ.
CHAIR LEMON. LEMON. AYE CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER 11 411 FOUR.
THE ROLL OPEN FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES AND FILE ITEM FOUR. AB
2292 BY PETRIE-NORRIS. DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
TEN ZERO. GONZALEZ LIMÓN LIMÓN.
AYE CIERTO CIERTO. NOT VOTING.
SKINNER. 11 ZERO. CURRENT VOTES
11 ZERO. NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
FIVE. AB 2815 PETRIE-NORRIS DO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 13
ZERO. GONZALEZ LIMON LIMON. AYE.
CIERTO CIERTO AYE. SKINNER 15
ZERO 15 ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIX AB
1826. CURRENT VOTE NINE THREE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO.
GONZALEZ LEMON. LEMON AYE.
NEWMAN. CIERTO CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER. TEN FOUR. CURRENT VOTE
TEN FOUR. MOVING ON TO ITEM
SEVEN AB 1834. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 13
ZERO. GONZALEZ. LIMON I LIMON I
CIERTO. OH I'M SORRY I AM SEVEN
1834 1830 COR TÔI SKINNER 15
ZERO. ZERO. CURRENT VOTES 15
ZERO. AND NOW MOVING ON. FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB 3238 DO PASS TO BE
AMENDED IN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. CURRENT VOTE 12 ZERO.
GONZALEZ LIMON. LIMON. NOT
VOTING CIERTO. CIERTO NOT VOTING
SKINNER. STERN I STERN I 13
ZERO. CURRENT VOTES 13 ZERO.
MOVING ON TO FALL. ITEM NINE
3246. CURRENT VOTE 11 ZERO.
GONZALEZ LEMON. LEMON I CIERTO
CIERTO I SKINNER. 13 ZERO.
CURRENT VOTES 13 ZERO. THAT'S
OUR YOU'RE UP ON ADUS ISSUES. SO
WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR SKINNER
AND DALLAS FORT WORTH ON THEIR
WAY. SENATOR SANDERS ON THE WAY.
SKINNER GONZALEZ ALSO JUST. DID
YOU DO THE VOTE? WE'RE JUST
GOING TO LET HER KNOW. COME.
RIGHT NOW. BUT. Ó 11 FOUR.
WHERE DO I HAVE THAT ONE? WILK.
NØ.
NO. WE JUST WAITED TO WALK OVER
THERE WAS CLOSED. WE'RE JUST
WALKING OUT OF MY STAFF ROOM
REAL QUICK. YES, YES. WHAT YES.
OH, DO YOU HAVE. DO YOU HAVE TO
WRITE IT?
YOU MAY. MAY I BEGIN? YES, MADAM
SKINNER? YES. NO PROBLEM. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLL FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM ONE, AB 691. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DO YOU PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS? CURRENT VOTE
11 FOR GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
SKINNER I SKINNER I 13 TO 413
FOR THAT MEASURE IS CLOSED. IT
IS OUT FILE ITEM FOR AB 2292. DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE 11 ZERO. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
A SKINNER. SKINNER I 13 ZERO 13
ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT AND
WE'RE CLOSE IT CLOSE THAT ITEM
NOW FOLLOWING M FIVE AB 2815 DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 15
ZERO. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER I SKINNER I 17 ZERO 14
ZERO 1717 ZERO. THAT MEASURES
OUT. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM NINE
3246. DID I DID I DID I DID I
MISS ONE? ITEM SIX I'M AT FILE.
I'M SORRY. FILING SIX AB 1826 DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE TEN
FOR GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
SKINNER. SKINNER I 12 412 FOUR.
THAT MEASURES OUT NEXT ITEM FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB 1834. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTES 15
ZERO. GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ. I
SKINNER. I SKINNER. I 17 ZERO 17
ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT NOW FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB 3238. DO PASS TO
BE AMENDED IN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. CURRENT VOTE 13 ZERO.
GONZALEZ NOT VOTING. OKAY.
SKINNER. SKINNER FOR NOT VOTING
13 ZERO 13 ZERO. THAT MEASURES
OUT FILE ITEM NINE AB 3246. DO
PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE 13 ZERO. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
I SKINNER. SKINNER I 15 ZERO 15
ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT OUR LAST
ITEM FILE ITEM 11 BY ADDIS AB
2537 DO PASS TO BE AMENDED IN
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE 11 ONE
IN GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER.
SKINNER I 13 113 ONE THAT
MEASURE THE MEASURES OUT MEMBER.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU, STAFF, AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.